- [Instructor] So what I
would like to do in this video
is graph the inequality negative 14 X
minus seven Y is less than four.
Like always, I encourage
you to pause this video
and see if you can graph it on your own
before we work through it together.
So the way that I like to do this
is I like to isolate a Y on
one side of this inequality,
and I'll do it on the left-hand side.
So the first thing I want
to do is let's get rid
of this negative 14 X here on the left.
So the best way to do that is to add 14 X,
but if I do that to the left-hand side
I also want to do that on
the right-hand side as well.
So I'm adding 14 X to both sides,
and that leaves me with
these two cancel out.
On the left-hand side I
have negative seven Y,
and that's going to be less
than, I have 14 X plus four,
or four plus 14 X.
14 X plus four.
And now I want to divide
both sides by negative seven
in order to isolate this Y.
But we have to be very,
very, very careful.
When you multiply or divide
both sides of an inequality
by a negative number,
you need to swap this,
you need to swap the inequality sign.
Instead of it being less than,
it would have to become greater than.
So if you divide both
sides by negative seven,
you are going to be left
with Y is greater than,
let me do that in a different color
just to highlight that
I'm swapping this around.
Y is gonna be greater than
14 divided by negative seven
is negative two X.
And then four divided by negative seven,
well that's negative 4/7.
And now I'm ready to graph this.
And the way that I would graph this,
I would graph Y is equal to
negative two X minus 4/7.
But since we're not greater
than or equal to it,
I would put a dotted line there
and just shade everything above that.
But let me just do what I'm talking about.
So let me draw some axes here.
So this is gonna be an
approximation obviously.
This is a hand-drawn graph
that we're dealing with.
So it's like that, that's my x-axis.
And let's see, our
y-intercept is negative 4/7,
which is a little bit more than 1/2.
So let's say that this right over here is,
let's say this right over here is one,
or negative one, I should say.
Actually, I think I'm
gonna have to put my axis
a little bit higher.
Let's do it like this.
So that is X.
Let's make this negative one.
And then that's about negative two.
And so this would be one,
and then this is going to be right about,
this is about one, and then
we have two right over there.
So we look at our y-intercept, when X is,
so let's just think
about what would we have
if we're thinking about Y is equal
to negative two X minus 4/7.
Well our y-intercept right over
here would be negative 4/7,
which is a little bit more than 1/2,
so it'll be roughly right around there.
And then we have a slope of negative two.
We have a slope of negative two.
So if you increase by one,
you are going to decrease by two.
So you're gonna decrease,
you're not gonna just go there,
you're gonna go right around there.
So you're gonna go right around there.
And I'm gonna get my ruler tool out
so I can actually draw that.
So I'll connect these two
dots with my ruler tool.
Now remember, I'm not just
trying to graph Y equals,
and in fact, this isn't
greater than or equal.
It's just strictly greater than.
So let me draw a dotted line there
to show that I'm actually not
going to include the graph
where Y equals negative two X minus 4/7.
So let me do that dotted line.
Dotted line right over there.
Show that I'm not, it's
not going to equal to that.
It's all the Y's for any X
that are greater than that.
My spacing is getting a little sloppy.
So that does the job.
There you go.
So that would be the line Y is equal
to negative two X minus
4/7, but I dotted lined it
because this isn't
greater than or equal to.
If it was greater than or
equal to I would fill it in,
but it's greater than to show
that we don't include the line
but we want all of the region,
all of the area above the line.
So let me shade that in.
So that's gonna be all of this,
actually I can shade it in with
a nice, big, juicy shading,
get the right tool out.
Alright, here we go.
So it would be all of
this area right over here,
would be what I would actually shade in.
So once again, I don't include the line.
I include everything above the line.
And I am done.